[Music]
if I gotta ask you you were just in
Russia is that right yeah I was in
Moscow Russia they gave me a star out
there they put my name down with you
know like they do out here in America
and gave me a stone they have a walk of
fame in Russia yeah they do I didn't
know that yeah it's only three people
only who's on it
Paris Hilton Sylvester Stallone and me
[Applause]
you're in great company exactly you know
I got a I'm a big admirer of yours
because you're always coming up with
something new I mean first of all you've
got this vaporizer and I do thank you
for this but you also have you also have
a snoop of I app yeah you have gone
cybertek you you have is an app that
allows you to dress up any picture to
snoop fi it yeah to make it feel like
you know you in my world because a lot
of people you know want to become a part
of my world I want to you know be able
to be a part of it so whatever better
way than to give them an opportunity to
use my application and add on to it okay
so for example we have some pictures
here like here's John Boehner who's been
snooping that's fantastic and then Brian
Williams you use the app on him fo
shizzle fo shizzle yeah they told me
there's one last one I haven't seen yet
there we go
[Applause]
I'm curious now I'm told that it costs
extra to have a cyber joint if you want
the the cigarette coming out of your
mouth you have to pay how much extra $99
what what are you talking to show that I
put that up again the one of me now that
thing coming out my mouth cost $99
$99.99 for a gold image of of cyber is
cyber yeah Gunnar's is virtual you've
gone too far
you've gone too far who would do that I
mean is me would pay that has anyone
paid $99 just for the image that's how
the gold that's not the images on your
face your people from your show paid
[Applause]
oh yeah we can't afford a real backdrop
but they paid for that